there is a new thing in this one for
both of you the underwater sequence yeah
that looked hard oh dear that was that
was pretty difficult it was a really
technical probably about a week at
Pinewood because we shot bill here in in
London and it was all underwater it's
the sequence where this sphere falls off
a cliff and she and another actor by the
name of justice are stuck inside of the
sphere and I'm on the outside of the
sphere trying to rescue them as it sinks
and your water is filling up the
gyrosphere and at one point we're
completely submerged in water and yeah
we we split I don't know maybe a week or
eight days or nine days we spent in
water yeah and it was I'll tell you they
put a lot of chlorine in the water
because you've got a crew of 85 people
just pissing this people we didn't have
time for people to pee so you knew
people were peeing
oh I'm certain people would suddenly
just
that was good pee face
doing that again
[Applause]
[Music]
sentence yeah I can called a little bit
when you you're not supposed to pee in
the pool but no one got out and because
I was I had to be underwater with my
eyes open
of course as if I could see with my eyes
open underwater grace DGP
I actually [ __ ] myself
time is money on a movie like this yes
you were in the border well I was
trapped in this gyrus fear no defense I
just thought this freedom as I was
working I just was like really present
Claire piece yes Claire was panicked
[Laughter]
every time you said that for the last
like seven months I'm like it was it's I
really made an effort to stay as
dehydrated as possible yes
[Music]